yes it's a time-honored tradition for
the Super Bowl to have fun whimsical
commercials it's another time-honored
tradition for the Super Bowl to have
30-second movie TV spot trailers and
it's another time-honored tradition for
youtubers to talk about that [ __ ] now
I'm gonna talk about this why because I
have a hard-on for comic book movies and
I love movies I'm not gonna talk about
all the movie trailers that happen
during the Superbowl but hey I'm gonna
talk about some the first one I saw a
Captain America Civil War it was a
really cool trailer again 30 seconds
what can you talk about a couple things
first of all the trailer it was great
because you hear everyone like united we
stand united wheezes chanting united we
stand and then it switches to you know
did we fall and then it shows more
conflict really cool imagery that locks
down the fact that hey I do want to see
my favorite heroes fight I guess my
favorite shot in the entire thing was
win Tony Stark is his Iron Man hand on
his hand and then Bucky pulls a gun on
him and he grabs the gun just goes boom
it's like all right first of all I
didn't though Iron Man's armor is
nine-millimeter point-blank bulletproof
good to know in his Civil War which is
that close call now look on his face
like are you you [ __ ] you did that oh my
god you Bucky
oh my god Bucky almost took off my hand
that mother for that guy him dick and
you see a better lineup of the two sides
before I was like all right they got
Hawkeye and I got where's ant-man it is
when you see ant-man with the line up
with Captain America side and then on
Iron Man's side you see the vision this
division this is the kind of goddess she
was a pretty advantageous person to have
in the fight against Ultron I don't know
that anyone on CAPS side can
particularly match to the vision so I
just feel like that's unfair as [ __ ]
everything you're gonna inner form
they're gonna find like vision
kryptonite I'm just saying cap sight has
a long road ahead of them because Iron
Man has vision don't know spider-man
though is hoping that the Superbowl
trailer would show spider-man at this
point I feel like spider-man shows but
you're gonna see spider-man in the movie
when you watch the movie so for me the
lineup was really cool I liked saying
the fact that ant-man was in there and
vision was in there but the thing that
made me want to talk about was that that
one scene where Tony Stark grabs the gun
and the gun just goes boom in his hand
did you feel like Tony Stark just dodged
a bullet
I'm gonna get some more trailer videos
coming to you supposedly who's gonna be
a Ghostbusters one on the Super Bowl I
hope that's true
but not all of them some of the movies
I'm gonna be like oh it's a Deadpool I'd
see that this week too white
about the trailer right now so the
Captain America Civil War Superbowl TV
spot have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]